you may not have heard us mention many
acronyms for native app monetization but
they do exist let's take a look at a few
of them first we talked about in-app
purchases a bit you may see this
abbreviated as I AP important metrics to
measure especially with I ap are AARP
you and a RPP you ARP you or average
revenue per user is calculated by
dividing your total revenue by your
total number of users AR ppu or average
revenue per paying user is calculated by
dividing the total revenue by the total
number of users that made a purchase the
advertising terms we discussed back in
the website monetization section also
apply here so if you wanted to implement
ads in your native app we recommend you
go back and check out that content now
it's once again time to test your memory
skills with another acronym challenge
see if you can recall the definitions
for each of these terms that we just
discussed enter their meanings in the
boxes provided